okay let's start today with a correction
yesterday I mistakenly said that FDR's
New Deal came after World War two it
came before World War two I misspoke
there and plenty of people wrote in and
said David you should correct and that's
what I'm doing okay we have news on the
Mexican border wall of course we've been
following this ever since Donald Trump's
campaign where he said he would build a
wall across the entire us-mexico border
and Mexico would pay for it nobody who
had any common sense believed that even
for a second and then this transitioned
into Donald Trump shutting down the
government because Americans wouldn't
pay for the border wall of course it was
Congress who ultimately decided that
they were not going to give Donald Trump
the money he wanted to start that border
wall we subsequently learned from
engineering reports about this border
wall that it's going to be an
impossibility to actually do it during
Donald Trump's presidency even if it
lasts six years because there is simply
no way that it's going to happen from a
logistical standpoint the prototypes of
the wall that were put together were
just that they were prototypes they
didn't account for actually getting all
of the materials and workers to the
places on the border that would be
required if we were indeed to build a
border wall across the entire border so
that's basically gone it's merely a
fantasy and so the question now is are
we going to have a shutdown at the end
of this week on February 15th if there
is no deal that includes some money for
some piece of Donald Trump's wall which
is really all that Donald Trump could
hope to get at this point at least
during this first term as president
Trump last night was giving a propaganda
rally in El Paso Texas he simultaneously
was sort of involved distantly with
negotiations happening between Democrats
and Republicans to see if indeed a deal
can be reached before we get to
potentially another government shutdown
there is a tentative agreement we are
being told it's an agreement in
principle but of course we have to see
how do people actually vote and is this
something that Donald Trump would get
behind and it includes not a single
penny for the us-mexico border wall
there is a billion dollars remember the
the full wall would cost according to
some engineering reports upward of fifty
billion dollars there is a billion
dollars potentially earmarked in this
new deal for what are called bollards
bollards are a particular type of
barrier that exists in some spots along
the us-mexico border
some call it border fencing and in
exchange for that Democrats have
successfully included in this
negotiation the reduction of 20 percent
of detention beds available to ice this
would be a really big deal and good for
the left because it would make it so
that ice has to be way more selective in
terms of who they detain it would make
the entire system have to work more
quickly because of the limited number of
detention beds that would be available
so that's a really good thing if it ends
up being part of the final deal and
Donald Trump seems to be totally
disconnected from reality as this is
going on as I mentioned he held a rally
in El Paso Texas last night he wrongly
claimed that El Paso is one of the most
dangerous cities in the United States
the reality is that it's been one of the
safest cities of its size in the United
States for a long time it was very safe
before they put in some border fencing
miles it remains safe after they put in
a little bit of border fencing and now
it is going to be up to Donald Trump is
Donald Trump going to choose to shut
down the border yet now the government
yet again which will have political
consequences or is Donald Trump going to
accept this deal that includes again
this sort of billion dollar token for
some bollards on the border and it's
really important to understand that
ballers aren't the wall bollards are
what we've been seeing in some spots for
a very very long time these have been
put up sporadically in different parts
of the border for years or is donald
trump going to accept it
and call it the wall and that is a very
very real possibility and it has the
real possibility of actually convincing
his supporters that he did it he's
building the wall but what is amazing
about this Pat is that the original
bipartisan Senate bill from December had
more than a billion dollars for border
fencing and Trump rejected it outright
if Trump had done nothing and by that I
mean no shutdown no to Oval Office
speeches about how we have an
immigration crisis if he had done none
of that stuff he could have had way more
than a billion dollars simply by saying
yes back in December I think that he may
take this deal because another
government shutdown or declaring a
national emergency both of those things
would be really bad for him politically
and he also has backed off the idea of
building a concrete wall like remember
during the government shutdown he talked
about installing steel slats this is
kind of similar he made he may accept
the billion dollars tolled towards
Bullards and call it a victory yeah and
what's important also to remember is
that there was a deal on the table a
full year ago that was a much bigger
package and it could have put almost
twenty five billion dollars not just for
a wall but for a bunch of border
security in exchange for permanent
status for daca recipients or at least a
path to citizenship really the art of
the deal right supposedly the best
negotiator he's waded out multiple
better deals from the perspective of the
wall builders and now he might have to
claim victory over a billion bucks for
some additional bollards I mean just an
amazingly bad negotiator and supposedly
he was going to be the negotiator in
chief that's why we were supposed to
vote for him truly unbelievable